l'année prochaine des départs et des
arrivées je vous le dis on a fait une
saison incroyable une saison record donc
merci à vous et l'année prochaine on va
encore essayer de grader le TPMP sachez
et vraiment je vous jure on n'a jamais
eu autant de demandes de personnes de
d'intégrer TPMP pour intégrer TPMP
des gens de tout bord c'est un truc de
fou je vous l'ai dit il y aura deux
animateurs très connus qui viendront
nous rejoindre il y a une personne qui
vient de la politique qui viendra nous
rejoindre il y a une personne
connue presque mondialement
non merci non merci non bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là non non vraiment
et il y aura l'année prochaine de
nouveau une chronique média sachez-le
comme à l'époque puisque je pense que
les médias vont venir très fort l'année
prochaine dans TPMP on aura une première
partie qui sera très médias sachez-le
jusqu'à 19h45 on débarras dès 18h
d'ailleurs les médias dès 18h et non
plus dès 18h40 les médias je vous donne
quelques infos les chiens et vous verrez
voilà et ensuite monsieur on sera dans
le magazine comme on fait mais il y aura
une chronique qui sera portée par un
garçon un nouveau talent
qui est très fort voilà si on comprend
bien il y a plus ici ça c'est
belle déduction
on est en train de travailler exactement
tout d'abord fait le séminaire mais
voilà on veut on veut on veut trouver on
veut optimiser sachez que C8 cette année
voilà je le redis a été loin devant tous
les toutes les tous les mois première
chaîne TNT on était vous le savez en
bagarre avec TMC l'année dernière TMC
avait pris le lit d'un sur C8 et là
cette année c'est C8 qui a vraiment pris
le lead et comme je l'ai dit l'année
prochaine on va chercher France 5 sachez
que du lundi au vendredi on est en ce
moment devant France 5 c'est le samedi
et le dimanche qui nous font défaut donc
on va renforcer fortement le samedi et
le dimanche pour pouvoir être non plus
première chaîne TNT mais
cinquième chaîne nationale voilà donc
c'est voilà notre objectif avec les les
patrons de C8 et voilà donc on va tout
mettre en oeuvre pour faire que C8 va
encore avancer encore grandir et encore
devenir plus fort plus haut comme disait
Tina
donc merci à vous est-ce que ça te fait
des frissons ce que je viens de dire
j'ai pas entendu ce que tu as dit en
fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le meilleur c'est le meilleur